i absolutely love you my husband is so
jealous i'm talking to you right now uh
he absolutely loves you as well so first
of all happy belated birthday thank you
how did you celebrate
uh i'm gonna
celebrate after this after i'm done with
work
this movie is absolutely amazing i
watched your first 38 minutes i it
really does live up to the hype how
would you say it lives up to the
multiverse hype are fans going to be
extremely excited to see this film
it seems so it seems like the it's it's
amazing to watch how the the ticket
ticket sites have crashed and people are
so excited about it and i don't think
they'll be disappointed and and it seems
like they really want to see it on a big
wide screen and i think that's really
the way to see this one
what ultimately convinced you to take on
this role because you don't fit the the
actual way and may look so how did what
made you say yes i'm going to take on
this role
i don't know i listen to my agents for
once
in my life
still debatable but
no you're amazing you changed the
character and that's what makes it so
unique and so special
yeah i love it and with this role uh you
know we see this relationship between
aunt may and peter parker actually grow
in the in the series uh how do you how
would you say that mma is dealing with
the fact that everyone knows peter
parker's identity
uh well i think she's pretty protective
and
uh really
also
um
trying to scheme with him really like
come come up with
ways to protect him but at the same time
have him engage and be able to get back
into the world
and for you to see tom holland really
absorb spider-man like he's become this
incredible character uh over the years
and just he's really owned it what does
it feel like to watch and become
spider-man
it's amazing because because he can turn
it
he he's just himself and then he
suddenly
the camera's on and he goes he goes back
in time he becomes younger and he has a
whole different uh energy and and voice
about him he's really it's amazing to
see him work yeah and there's a lot of
super villains in this film is do you
have one that particularly that you like
or enjoy watching
i don't i don't know who's in this film
so i don't know if that's a trick
question or if you're trying oh you know
it's in the trailer
[Laughter]
okay
yeah there's a few there so i was just
hoping oh yeah
bro there's no no i'm not trying green
dolphin i'd get in trouble
green goblin yeah maybe you have a
favorite super villain green goblin
yes yes
yeah and one of the things that we also
see in the storyline is the fact that
peter parker asked dr strange to make a
spell rather than dealing with the
scrutiny of the media and people knowing
his name uh do you think he did the
right thing
uh well
he did that he did the thing he went
with his instinct and his instincts are
usually really good that tingle that he
has so that's mm-hmm happy birth happy
birthday thank you congratulations on
the film enjoy the ride thank you